first question here in the third row hey
Steph congratulations on your career
high in the playoffs my question for you
is you play the hunt over 100 games
without clay or a hundred games with
clay talk to us about not have them
tonight and kind of have that me any
injury and then playoffs is tough but
especially a guy like clay who's been so
durable in his whole you know career and
especially in the playoffs and the way
he had been playing as of late so you
know there's no secret that were a
little injury plagued now and and you
know guys trying to just find a way back
to the court but you know the moment is
now you got to try to have next man up
mentality like we always say and just go
out and fight we did that tonight we can
play better obviously better on the
defensive end but I like the
competitiveness that we had
understanding you know we're missing 50
points pretty much between Katie and
clay so well we'll adjust and it's a
long series you know it's going to be
it's going to be fun for us Friday I
mean I'm not sure that process takes
care of itself when you know with the
work that they're putting in our
training staff and all that stuff Jeanne
McCauley from ap each time you you had a
big shot it seemed like they they found
an answer every time from from multiple
guys how difficult was that I mean they
just they came down and hit big shot
after big shot
yeah they play well no game like you
said every time we made a run or got the
crowd into it they either made a tough
three or there was a tough you know foul
call and they slowed the tempo down or
something went their way so you know
it's just how it goes sometimes you have
to tip their captor you know all the
guys that made you know pivotal plays
and in the right times
I think defensively in the first quarter
we can get off to a better start to
hopefully take a little bit of rhythm
away I think we it was you know giving
up 36 in the first quarter stuff
especially you know with a couple of
guys down on our end so we got to
correct that for Game four but like you
said they play well they deserved a win
tonight way tonight the Guardian a Steve
Kerr told us before the game tonight
that clay was desperate to get on the
court what was his reaction when the
training staff told him that was what
was that like to witness I didn't see it
actually no so I don't really really
know if there were any fireworks or
anything like that but you know clay was
like you said he was giving it
everything he had to be out there
tonight I think wisdom prevailed in
terms of this is a potentially seven
game series and you'd like to you know
take advantage of tonight but his
overall health is important in terms of
you know not taking away the rest of us
you know of the series with something
catastrophic happiness so hopefully he's
back for Game four hey Steph Phil barber
Santa Rosa Press Democrat with clay out
it looked like you were pretty
aggressive right from the start did you
have a little extra sense of urgency in
terms of sense of urgency in terms of
scoring as opposed to times when maybe
you would distribute if you had all of
your pieces on the floor for sure yeah
oh I'll ask a follow-up it looked like
they had very physical defense against
you I know you're used to that
especially in the playoffs anything
different that they were doing were they
any more physical than you're accustomed
to not really you know after the two
games you started to get a feel of what
what's available on that end of the
floor
just trying to make the right reads and
you know for the most part we not even
myself just we were aggressive getting
into the paint and swinging the ball we
were a little rushed early but you're
just trying to create good offense and
you know I think this is the third game
in a row we score 109 it's just a matter
of our defense defense and we can't fall
into the trap of thinking you know
offense alone that's gonna win win us
you know another championship and we're
letting that into the floor affect our
defense and that'll be the biggest
adjustment for us game for in the center
CJ Peterson San Francisco Examiner Steph
in game 2 you guys got pretty you know
break out a good breakout game from
DeMarcus but tonight he kind of seemed a
little bit of regression kind of got
exploited defensively in the block only
was 1 for 7 from the floor what did you
see from his game and what do you see
what he would like to see him do
differently before Dan came for and
beyond there's nothing different he
should do just continue to play with
confidence and you know there was a
rough go in terms of when he had the
ball in his hands there were some some
calls that you know we're a little iffy
honestly in terms of him being
aggressive in the paint and not be able
to finish for a lot of different reasons
defensively it's all five guys being on
a string and you know that's that's
something we pride ourselves on one guy
two guys aren't gonna you know do the
job by themselves and and we can help
cover each other so like any great
player you know if you have a rough game
you know that resiliency to bounce back
and in the confidence to notice you can
still go out there and impact the game I
said there's something that he'll help
bring and and we all will follow suit
for sure mark here
front his stuff out mark Medina bear in
his group not only did he have a lot of
points st. but it look like you're
involved with a lot of hustle plays I
was wondering if you could take us
through your approach with that your
just competitiveness and trying to play
to the to the buzzer so it's the finals
whatever you try to do to win the game
so nothing special to be honest it's
just trying to make the right play you
know give everything you got sacrifice
your body when you have to have the
opportunity there guys are not team to
do that on nightly basis tonight just
happy to be in a losing effort so got to
keep that same mentality and and just
play a full 48 like we like we're
accustomed to doing do last three in the
back corner mark and then over here Josh
Lewin Berg TSN Steph you saw a lot of
Fred vanvleet in the second half tonight
as well as in the series and in the
regular season meeting what does he do
defensively to challenge you
he's just consistent he they usually try
to you know have him press up full court
trying to make me work I just try to you
know make the simple decision continue
to you know try to get down hill in the
painting and honestly they the way they
load their defense you know in
transition sometimes and or even in the
half court he knows he has help behind
him so he can be a lot more aggressive
on the ball and they give him the
freedom to do that but you know like
tonight from the start I felt like I
could get to where I wanted to go on the
floor and just a matter if you make or
miss and make the right play you know
distributing the basketball and that'll
continue the rest of the series so I
know they got bodies that they can throw
at me where this him Danny Green Kyle
Lowry of Holmes and they have helped you
know and behind them just got to be
aggressive like I've been trying to make
the right play and we live with the
shots that it did I'd say marking the
third row Steph mark Schwartz ESPN
caller he seems to be a barometer for
how the Raptors
and what sense was that true tonight and
in this series he's such a smart
basketball player
and he controls a lot of the pace for
them nights where he gets it going
scoring was he can make it tough on you
because I do have a lot of weapons
around and they like the space of floor
he has a ball in his hands a lot as a
distributor but when he can turn it on
you know putting the ball in the basket
it's just you know that much tougher so
you know he made shots tonight and you'd
see if your cap to him because you know
he was he's willing to take him and we
just got it know where he is on the
floor just be able to use length and
some bodies at him make him try to play
in the crowd but I think historically
speaking in the playoffs when you play
as well they usually go and we got to do
something about it last question on the
agenda from the border coach mentioned
that you guys Walker Hardy in the fourth
quarter
even though they got a big lead you guys
you know for school Forster of turnover
and the gallery bounds how proud are you
of you guys tonight
I mean we fought but we lost so we got
to go back to the drawing board and just
recalibrate for Game four it's kind of
been like a roller coaster type of
series these first three games and I
like the I like the things that we saw
tonight that we can make adjustments on
and and protect home court you know on
Friday so we're gonna compete no matter
no matter what happens you can count on
that so just got to execute and play
smarter and no matter who's out there on
the floor do what you got to do to it to
win it's the finals man my opportunity
for us to you know get back in the
series on Friday and take it from there
Thank You Stefan this concludes the
session in here for tonight